- [Mark] All right. Antoinette.
Antoinette. where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Antoinette] Los Angeles, California.
- [Mark] South central?
- [Antoinette] Yes.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
Did you have both your
parents when you were a kid?
- No, I didn't. Just had my mother.
- [Mark] Where was dad?
- In and out of prison.
- [Mark] Was he ever in your life?
- Yes.
- [Mark] What age did
you have your dad around?
- Like six or seven years old, he left.
- [Mark] So he was gone
after you were six?
- Hmm. And my stepdad stepped
in and took over. And...
- [Mark] Oh I see.
So how was your childhood?
- You said, how was it?
- [Mark] How was it
- Rough.
- [Mark] Any like abuse
or traumatic events
or anything like that?
- I've been through a lot.
Abuse, yeah.
- [Mark] From your mom, dad, step dad?
- Real dad.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- [Mark] You real dad?
- Yeah. Getting whoopings and yeah.
- [Mark] So what kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Hmm?
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in high school?
- I was, I would say I was
off the chain in high school
and junior high and high school.
- [Mark] Were drugs part of the picture?
- Weed, yeah.
Weed and ecstasy.
- [Mark] And now you're working Figueroa?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How long have
you been doing this?
- I've been working in
Figueroa for like six years.
- [Mark] And how old are you now?
- 17.
- [Mark] You've been doing
this since you were 11?
- Yeah. 11, 12.
- [Mark] Wow.
You were working with
a pimp when you started
or how'd you get started
in this at 11 years old?
- Well when I started, I was fully built.
How I am now.
And I was real mature for my age. So...
- [Mark] So you looked older?
- Yes, I did.
I start like body, at like
10 years old, titties, ass
and everything. Yeah.
- [Mark] And the guys
that would pick you up
were aware that you were 11 years old?
- No.
- [Mark] You would give him
the impression you're older.
- Hmm.
- [Mark] Have you ever
been arrested for this?
- Yes I have.
- [Mark] It's a dangerous lifestyle,
have you had guys give you a hard time?
- Oh yes, plenty of them.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff has happened?
- Might've been raped, robbed, jumped on
after I did the service.
Yes.
- [Mark] So do your parents
know you're doing this?
- My parents, I really don't
talk to them anymore. At all.
- [Mark] Did you run away at a young age?
- I've been on my own
since I was like 12, 13.
Yeah.
- [Mark] And so you're
in high school right now?
- I'm not in school at all.
- [Mark] Have you been to high school?
- I was in enrolled
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- I said I was in enrolled
- [Mark] Oh, I see, but you didn't go?
- No.
- [Mark] And do you have kids of your own?
- No I don't.
- [Mark] You don't.
- No.
- [Mark] But you're pregnant right now.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How far along are you?
- Eight months.
- [Mark] You're eight months?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] And you're
still working Figueroa?
- Yes, I am.
- [Mark] The guys that pick you up,
- Yes they do
- [Mark] They must know
that you're pregnant.
It's hard to hide.
And guys are okay with that.
- Yes they are.
You have some that want pregnant women.
You have some that's their fetish.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Do you know who the dad is?
- No.
- [Mark] You don't know who the dad is.
- [Mark] Was it one of
your customers maybe?
- I believe it was one of my customers
that I have been fucking for a while.
- [Mark] And not using a condom.
- Probably something that happened.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So how much money do you make now?
A day?
- Well, since I've been
pregnant or before?
- [Mark] Either one.
You make more being pregnant or less?
- I make more being
pregnant on a good night.
- [Mark] And what's a good night total up?
- Since I've been pregnant
700 and then tips.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Have you worked
with a pimp before?
- No.
- [Mark] Never.
And are drugs a part of your life now?
- Weed and ectasy. That's it.
- [Mark] That's it.
Does this lifestyle
get you down sometimes?
You get depressed over doing this?
- Yeah, when it's slow.
- [Mark] (chuckles) When
business is slow you get there.
- When business is slow yes I do.
- [Mark] Do you find that
doing this builds your,
some kind of self-esteem boost?
Getting guys that are all attracted to you
and paying you and...
- Yes.
- [Mark] Getting a lot of
attention from guys on the street.
- Yeah. Yes.
- [Mark] Is that the
attraction that you think
for a lot of the girls that do it?
- Yes. That's why they continue to do it.
- [Mark] You think?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you think
you're addicted to this?
- Yeah. I mean, it's something
that I won't stop doing.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Mark] After you have the
baby you'll still do it?
- Yeah
- [Mark] And you're gonna keep the baby?
- Yes. I'm gonna still be out
there working 24 hours a day
seven days a week.
- [Mark] To support your family.
- To support me and my child.
- [Mark] Just you and your baby?
- Yes.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- Doing this?
- Just, I mean, in general.
I mean your favorite
memories in your short life,
17 years old.
- Just touching (indistinct)
and touch money.
I like money.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Money makes you happy.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Do you think doing
this since you were 11 years old
has changed you somehow?
You think you'd be a different
girl if you had gotten a job
at a fast food restaurant
or something like that?
- Guess I would still
wanna hustle on the side,
cause I feel like a
little gig on the side,
like a square job,
that's not enough money,
especially a restaurant.
So I was still wanna hustle on the side.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Have you ever had a boyfriend?
- Yeah
- [Mark] Outside of this,
- No
- [Mark] Outside of your customers?
- Yes I have.
- [Mark] You have?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] Because doing this as a job
kind of gets in the way
of that sometimes, right?
- Yes it does.
- [Mark] The guys have a
hard time handling the fact
that you're doing this all night.
- Hmm.
It's either, it's a problem with that.,
or they want the money.
- [Mark] Yeah, they turn into your pimp.
- Yeah, and I'm not going for that.
- [Mark] That's not gonna happen.
- It's not gonna happen.
- [Mark] So if a young girl
were considering doing this
what advice would you give her?
- I would tell her to don't do it,
and just stay in school
and to find another hustle.
Yes.
- [Mark] For what reasons?
Cause it's dangerous?
- Yeah it's dangerous.
- [Mark] Are you worried
about the life of your baby
knowing that her mom or his mom
is going to be doing this
every night to make money?
- Yes.
Anything could happen.
- [Mark] Anything could happen?
- Yes.
- [Mark] At some you have
to think for your child too.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Will you have your
family helped you at all
with the raising of the baby?
- No.
- [Mark] Just on your own?
What's the craziest thing
that's happened to you
since you've been doing it?
- Since I've been doing this?
- [Mark] Yeah.
(Antoinette exhales loudly)
- I did have to run out to
one's house asshole naked
after I finished a service.
I did damn near ended up
on crutches in a hospital
after I did finish a service.
I tried to get out this guy's
car to get to the front seat,
to grab my bag, and this
drove motherfucker drove off
F-150 truck.
I'm hanging on the side of the truck,
telling him, like I just want my bag.
But as he's driving off, he's dragging me
And I did been jumped on
numerous times by clients
after I finished a service.
Yes.
- [Mark] Did you notice at some point
that the lines that you'll cross
in terms of like what you're okay with
and what you're not okay with
have changed over the years?
- Like...
- Like maybe when you started,
you said "oh I would never do that."
And then as time goes
on, you find yourself
doing those things that
you once would not do
- Anal.
- [Mark] Like that.
- Yes.
- [Mark] You're doing that now?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You make more money for that?
- Hmm. Yes.
- [Mark] So you didn't have much school,
but working the streets all these years,
since you were 11 you got
a lot of street smart.
- [Antoinette] Yes.
- [Mark] What do you think
you've learned working the street
that has helped you?
- [Antoinette] As far as the streets?
- [Mark] Yeah. I mean like,
I'm sure there's things
there's knowledge that you've gained
from working the streets.
- [Antoinette] Who not to
trust and who to trust.
Although my trust level
is, I don't trust no one
- [Mark] Your intuition is probably...
- [Antoinette] Yes
- [Mark] Heightened, right?
- [Antoinette] Yeah.
That and like, I got smarter.
I'm real street smart.
Yeah.
- [Mark] What kind of future
do you think your child will have?
I mean you're doing a job
where you can get arrested
any night or worse.
- [Antoinette] Yes.
- [Mark] And what's gonna happen...
- [Antoinette] Or even getting killed.
- [Mark] Exactly.
And what's gonna happen to your baby
if mom doesn't come home?
- [Antoinette] I think about
that all the time. I do.
I've been thinking about a
few things that I wanna do
after I have the baby,
but this is still gonna be my hustle.
You know cause it will be
hard to get out the game.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What's been the best experience
you've had doing this?
- I really haven't had no.
Imma keep it real with you, I haven't.
- [Mark] It's just a rough life.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And there's
no other option for you
that works for you?
- Like first, like other, like jobs?
- [Mark] Other jobs, or
other careers or other?
- No, because it's like, once
you've been doing it so long
it's like, what else, you know.
I always tell myself like if I get a job
I want it to be a good paying job
to where I don't have to still
go hustle to make ends meet.
But yeah.
That's why I said that I will get a job
and still hustle on the side.
I still have my regular customers.
- All right, Antoinette,
thank you so much for talking with me.
Good luck with your baby and your future.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thanks.